st. Patrick's Day is one of the most
globally celebrated Saints days across
the world there are green festivities on
March 17th as far and wide as Japan
Argentina and Russia sympatric stay is
widely celebrated for a number of
reasons the most significant being Irish
mass migration there are approximately
70 million people on earth with Irish
blood emigration has been part of Irish
history since at least the Middle Ages
but it peaked during the Irish Famine of
the 1840s a quarter of the population
left seeking new lives mostly in America
the United Kingdom Canada and Australia
surprisingly some patrick's day as we've
come to know it was invented in America
in 1762 Irish soldiers marched through
New York City beginning the traditional
sin patrick's day parade today parades
are held in many different countries
with revelers downing thirteen million
pints of Guinness
but there's another secret to the
success of San Patrick's Day Irish pubs
it's estimated there are 8,500 Irish
pubs around the world from Nepal to
Dubai and even Mongolia the deluge of
drinking establishments is thanks in
part to Guinness who in the 1990s began
exporting its concept of the Irish pub
around the world providing designs and
advice to aspiring publicans
and if they wanted it even shipping them
a prebuilt bar in the past 25 years
Guinness has helped open pubs in more
than 150 countries around the globe
the Irish government is trying to
capitalize on the country's growing fame
this year its ministers will travel to
over 50 different nations and cities to
promote their country and it's working
brand Ireland is now one of the fastest
growing nation brands in the world
launcher
[Music]